how many Lamborghinis have you had in
your entire life we had my original
Gallardo I bought my daughter a
Lamborghini Gallardo for her 19th
birthday my gated you're gated guyardo
and then I had the Squadron Corsa and
you had the Squadron Corso which is the
ultimate Gyarados so there's four there
we had four huracans we had my original
Huracan we had the twin turbo we had the
aperta where we cut the windshield off
of it I mean it came like that factory
like that from Lamborghini and then we
have the current one we have yeah okay
so four and then we had the Urus a nurse
I have the Murcielago I had a Murcielago
you had a Murcielago we have two
Aventadors and we had uh Diablo Espy how
many is that totally I think it's like